ladies and gentlemen brian rose just
ended his career
in an interview with some kids as part
of a show called
politics relaxed this is a show done by
teenagers and i think brian thought it
would be an easy way
for him to get some nice publicity but
little did he know
these young little journalists are
aspiring to hold politicians accountable
and they put brian over the fire
you've deleted comments of your channel
that even vaguely
even vaguely against what you're doing
like
we have a we have a social media team
which is the one thing
as my publisher said i've actually got a
commitment as he said
20 minutes he didn't do well and now
he's censoring them
he's deleted their video from their
channel it's their content
he has copyright strike that video
taken it down so he can't be criticized
by children let me remind you that this
is the man who says
that he's pro free speech he's the man
who said he's the free speech guy
you can say anything right this is the
guy who was censoring
children who took him to task on his
inherent contradiction
and lies we're going to talk about it
today and i'm going to signal boost it
because these poor kids
need someone to fight for them you know
they have a small youtube channel
they can't get the word out and it's up
to us to put a stop to this because look
brian rose can censor me he can be a
hypocrite all he wants
with other adults look i can take it but
you can't do this
to kids who are entering politics and
bully them around
you coward and fraud i'm gonna call you
out
ladies and gentlemen let's go to the
board welcome to the 10 million dollar
studio i'm your host
coffee zilla and today yes we're talking
about
brian again the hypocrisy the lies this
is it i'm telling you guys i really
believe this is going to be the
interview
that um really destroys this man's whole
career any last shred of credibility he
had which hardly was any
is gone after this debate any last
remnant
of his former reputation from london
real and all the interviews they did
there
is gone after today now let me remind
you that brian rose he's right now
running for mayor of london and one of
his big policies is free speech as you
know he ran the freedom
uh platform which we've covered in many
videos but he also says this extends
this
right to free speech extends to even his
critics
let's take a listen real quick to set up
this clip because you guys aren't going
to believe this
we don't have people hating us then
we're doing something wrong so
i actually welcome it i think it's
fascinating
but also i'm a big believer in free
speech so there you go
guys he doesn't mind it that's what he's
been saying
but as you and i both know this has not
been true he's been censoring
all my videos where i talk about him
anytime i show his clips
he tries to get those videos removed but
then
this interview with these kids happened
where brian rose i guess
thought he was going to get a softball
interview but he does this and he takes
down
these kids video challenging him on some
of the most important
issues and contradictions of his
campaign let's take a listen to this
because these kids
demolish brian um i want to ask you um
after doing a bit of research when you
said you wanted to be held accountable
so i'm going to do that but do you stand
for freedom of speech since you delete
you delete comments we clearly stand for
freedom of speech i mean that's why we
created that platform
so in the uh in the freedom of speech
you've deleted comments that are
that are saying things against you um
against some of your
work but yet you're happy to give a
platform to somebody who denies the
holocaust
what is the deal i can't confirm or deny
that
it is so unbelievable to me that these
kids it's taken
kids to hold brian to account all the
other interviews
no one has been this hard on brian so
just imagine the irony brian thought
this is going to be his
easiest interview of the entire day and
these kids are
ripping him to shreds and i talked to
the kid after he said look i just want
to know are you consistent with your own
values he's doing a journalist's
job you want him to be consistent that's
your point about holding him accountable
100 and if he wants to talk about free
speech and if that's what he really
wants to push
that's fine as long as he's actually
like committing to these actions but
what we've seen over the last
weeks and months of this campaign is he
cannot
do that he's deleting comments and he's
now stopping our video
from being released dude imagine having
such a fragile ego that you get
destroyed in a debate
by a kid and then you censor their video
i mean honestly i think they should be
getting jobs at the bbc
to be honest like news organizations
should pay attention
this is the kind of journalism that we
need with politicians by the way
but watch as brian tries to redirect out
of this
these hard questions that monitors that
again we don't believe in hate speech
and we don't believe in anything that
insides violence so but actually what
what what i really like to talk about is
knife crime putting police on the
streets
i completely know what you're talking
about
you were talking about your speech which
is
20 minutes so we're just after the hour
so howard's just giving me a shake here
this is brian running away he apparently
said before the interview he's going to
stay for like 30 to 45 minutes
he's running early from the interview
because he has to
he he's getting crushed uh he left early
so we are on schedule for 30 minutes he
only came off 15
um and the reason he left was because we
were challenging on him deleting
comments
uh which like goes exactly against what
he's talking about free speech
so look we can pick this up at another
time but i really
i really appreciate the time guys and we
can pick this up next time we talk
all right thank you very much there we
go that is brian rose
the mayoral candidate who is avoiding
scrutiny these kids are
everything right with journalism
they're doing the real journalism that
brian rose says isn't happening
they're really holding politicians to
account
and their channel is being censored
right now and quite frankly i don't
think any of us
should stand for it get a hold of
youtube we need to fight for these kids
to have their video reinstated and brian
rose to be held account for the fact
that he is
bullying kids into silence while at the
same time complaining about youtube
bullying him what does it say about you
when you're bullying
as a 2 million subscriber channel a
channel with a few thousand subscribers
i think it's
absolutely deplorable i think these kids
are doing everything right and guys
please go subscribe to their channel and
give them some love
this is the future of journalism right
here and i really believe that this
interview
more than any other demonstrates the
hypocrisy
the lies of brian rose the con man
and is going to destroy his career
because you can't stand up
for free speech when you are censoring
children
kids from talking politics with you
absolutely disgusting i hope this stops
wanted to give a big shout out to these
kids for doing everything
right thank you for watching guys uh and
quick emergency broadcast i'll see you
guys in the next one
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick trying to sell
me on a dream but
that was where you lost me wake up and
smell the coffee